m
[Silence]
sub
was
[Silence]
We are continuing in the chapters
regarding the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam Miracles there are many books
written on this topic as we've mentioned
before
previously some of these books are very
and of course these miracles of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam they
are spread and they are peppered
throughout the books
of Hadith and history and also
throughout the Quran Allah subhanahu wa
taala mentions
many miracles of the Prophet s. wasam
honestly it's very very difficult to be
able to enumerate and name every
single miracle that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
performed his prophethood was an
abundance of good and blessing and and
miraculous in
itself and Allah subhanahu waala
mentions this in the
Quran
[Silence]
Allah subhah
wa eludes to this in a verse in Surah
Al Iman
in which he mentions that he has sent to
us the book The Quran which is recited
to us and amongst us is his
messenger so we see here that Allah
subhanahu
wa gave us not only the Quran but as
well the messenger to deliver the
Quran and Allah subhanahu waala has
referred to the Quran as a light and he
is referred to the prophet s. wasam as a
light as
well and so it's very hard to enumerate
all of these Miracles that the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam performed or
performed for him we spent our last
session discussing the miracle of the
Quran we discussed it miraculous nature
and that it is not only
miraculous in its
structure and its eloquence but as well
miraculous in its wisdom miraculous in
its knowledge miraculous in its
prophecies miraculous in its benefits
miraculous in its guidance Etc when
Allah subhanahu waaa challenges the
enemies of the Prophet Sall alai wasam
to produce a chapter the Quran
here doesn't just mean in eloquence
the Quran in eloquence no the Quran
is not just is not just Superfluous
in itself it's not just
eloquent but much art and a
lot of Art and poetry is an art you'll
see that it's very wellmade very well
done very Vivid but its message is kind
of hollow often
times it does very well to capture
whatever the poet is trying to say or
whatever the author is is mentioning but
it is lacking in wisdom forite Etc the
Quran does not have this is issue it is
of the utmost of
eloquence it is
concise and as well the Quran is
incredibly
has an an abundance of wisdom and
blessedness in it and
so the challenge is not just from that
aspect from the aspect of eloquence and
structure this is important for us to
understand because many people are under
the under the false
impression the
misconception that the miraculous nature
of the Quran was its eloquence that's
correct that's just one dimension of
many the Quran is potent is powerful it
is a
Criterion and the Quran itself makes a
lot of claims Allah
subhana lays claim to a lot of things if
we look at how Allah praises the Quran
in the Quran he Praises its eloquence he
Praises its structure he Praises its
wisdom he praises
its accuracy
Etc these are some very
lofty
claims yet these claims are
only are only
reinforced with time they're not
unraveling with time these claims these
prophecies these they're not unraveling
with time we're not advancing and
realizing learning more about the world
around us and realizing that this is the
words of a man who didn't know much
about how the world works this is not
happening as a matter of fact the Quran
is always a few steps ahead of us no
matter where we reach we find it's been
there
right and so the fact that the Quran
can be have such a wide audience a broad
audience not only of culture and place
but also
time 1,500 years ago is a very different
place a very different world than our
world today might as well be a different
Universe however we see that the Quran
is just as relevant just as accurate
just as wholesome As It Ever Was and
this is a testament to the fact that
this is not the words of a man this is
not the words of a man human
being no matter who this person is once
you know the person a lot of some of or
much of the
Allure dissipates you
know memorize a piece of poetry
or long no matter how catchy it is no
matter how attractive some something is
that is made by human beings over time
it
wears and it becomes
redundant see the Quran doesn't have
that issue and
so this is a testament to the accuracy
and the Divinity the
Divine the divine origin of the Quran
that the Quran is the literal
word of Allah subhanahu
waala as spoken by Allah to jel as jel
narrated it and related it to the
prophet Sall wasam none of it has been
lost none of it has been changed none of
it has been altered or
adulterated and
so this is an incredible Miracle of
Allah subhanahu wa taala but there were
many many many other miracles
andl he
mentions that there has never been a
prophet
sent and particularly those mentioned in
the
Quran except that the prophet Muhammad
s. wasam as being their cap as being the
the last laid brick in the temple of
prophethood if you will
the last piece of prophethood to
complete the
picture we see that any miracle any
Prophet before him
had our Prophet sallallahu alai had the
same Miracle
or a a miracle of the same
kind that is usually Superior to those
Miracles before so for
instance the prophet s.
wasam was narrated to have cured a
blind man similar
to
Allah split the sea for him Allah
split the moon for the prophet Muhammad
s
wasam and not every one of these things
happened to him personally
personally any miracle that happens any
miraculous thing that
happens to his companions or his
followers they are experiencing that
Miracle because of who because of his
prophethood his messengership and so
those Miracles are considered of
his this is why the
scholars mentioned miraculous things
that occurred
in the time of the companions in the
time of
the and they considered them miracles of
the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaih
wasallam this is not to mean that he's
not he's still alive performing Miracles
what this means is any miracle that is
of his legacy is of his
miracles so for
instance
in
the Quran Allah mentions
that was able to speak to the
dead this is something that was
prophesized by the prophet sallallah
alai wasam and the narration of AA and
others some Scholars grade it as an
authentic narration either way it is An
Occurrence that happened
that said that we were told
you know when a companion says we were
told what does that mean we the
companions were told by the prophet
sallallah wasallam we were told that a
man of this umah will speak after death
and this happened in the time of the
companions to one of the very well-known
likewise for instance
I was thrown into the fire Allah subhah
said and the fire burned around him and
did not burn him this happened in the
time
of to a man known
as
from in the time
of is a major narrator of Hadith and he
was of the first generation who took
from the
companions we see that his house burned
down while he was asleep
inside
and when the house was smoldering and
finishing its its you know it was
burning down and he was unaware of this
he woke up with the house burned down
around him unharmed in any way and when
heard of this he
demanded to
meet and so forth and so these are
things that have
occurred important that we as Muslims
not allow ourselves and allow our
narrative to become
cheapened what do I mean by
that you notice modern Western
Christianity it happens a lot other Rel
religions but Christianity
specifically someone will order a
hamburger right order a hamburger from
McDonald's and look at the Patty it
looks Jesus right take pictures of
it is a miracle this hamburger or this
chicken nugget looks Jesus
right this is laughable and this is
something that cheapens our narrative
when we see Muslims doing this for
instance since I saw a
video you know a guy took some
seed some chicken
feed and he put it down on the ground in
the and he made you know spread it out
to say Allah in AR then he had a chicken
come and eat
it then he played the video backwards so
what's it look it looks the
chicken is laying down the seeds right
Subhan Allah look how the chicken took
its food and made a in their
dirt Allah and everybody sends this out
all over the world WhatsApp is buzzing
with a chicken writing Allah in the dirt
somewhere you know Allah where is
this place where is this Village this is
the kind of ignorances that we see
happen this is something that we should
never allow ourselves
to
it's laughable right it's laughable
this is not something that you know
or for instance they will take a
video of a goat goat is you know making
noise look the goat is saying yeah Allah
listen Allah right it sounds yeah
Allah the goat is saying yeah Allah
Subhan Allah right this is this is
something that that we should not
encourage we should not spread we should
not
circulate right these are the kinds of
things that
a you know because a miracle is the
reflection of the one who performs that
Miracle right it's a reflection of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam it's
an ultimately a reflection of Allah
subhana wa tala's will and his actions
right he's the one that causes these
Miracles and so Allah subhanahu waala
making a chicken right Allah in Arabic
and bird seed or having a goat say
Allah or things this this is it it
cheapens our
narrative and so the Miracles of the
Prophet sallallah alai wasam are very
numerous some of the scholars the
earlier
Scholars mentioned that they are over
a
thousand attempted to mention all of the
narrations all of the chapters of
Miracles of course no person could
really you
know gather every single miracle that
happened it's too
expansive I
mentions the G and most known of these
miracles in this
[Silence]
chapter
so he tells us no we tells us may Allah
have mercy upon him that as for the
Miracles of the Prophet
Sall other than the
Quran he says it is not possible to
enumerate and name all of them because
they are extremely numerous and they are
continuous
as we said based on that principle
everything miraculous that happens to
the followers of the Prophet s. wasam
who are known for following him those
are considered miracles of his legacy
and miracles of his legacy are miracles
of
his he says but we will mention a few of
them the first one he mentions is the
splitting of the the moon
right this is a narration which is
inkari it's in Muslim a number of
companions an narrates
thisd narrates this and this is
mentioned in the
Quran Prophet Allah subhanahu waala said
in the opening verses
of he
says
that the hour has drawn near the hour of
judgment has drawn near and the moon has
split moon has
split the story behind this is that
some of the antagonists of the Prophet
sallallah alaihi wasallam from amongst
the
the demanded of the Prophet
s that he provide them with a miracle
that is
irrefutable
and the prophet Sall wasam made Dua to
Allah that he make this miracle that
could be seen by all and would be
irrefutable and so Allah subhanahu waala
sent Revelation to him that you have a
choice you're now at a junction make a
decision we can perform this
miracle and if your
people reject it in spite of the
miracle they will be completely
destroyed because this means that there
will be no hope for them
or you can leave them as they
are in hopes that some in the future may
become
Muslim and so the prophet sallallah alai
wasam chose the latter he chose to not
perform this
miracle after this
incident
the moon was
split and it was split at a time when it
was full
over
Mecca and it was
split far enough apart that a
mountain
peak appeared to be between the two
halves and the prophet Sall alai wasam
said to the people of qur
is bear witness to this see this and so
everyone who was out at that time saw
this witnessed
this but in
in qur or in polytheist
fashion they started to say muhamad that
Muhammad has done some kind of magic to
us to make us see this to hallucinate
this they said
so let us wait to see Travelers who come
in the next few days and ask them if
they saw anything of
note right they saw anything of worth
mentioning in their
travels and so
as was expected Travelers began to
arrive in Mecca and each one of these
Caravans was
excited and
awe
struck by what they had seen the night
of the Moon splitting that the moon had
split we saw this we watched this happen
and we saw it
reform now this is something that Allah
of
wa mentioned in the Quran the opening
verse of he
says the hour has drawn near and the
moon has
split this is one of the
most recited chapters of the Quran in
major occasions so
inah often times Sal when everybody is
there the prophet Sall alai wasallam
would recite this chapter of the
Quran
right and why is this important he would
recite
and why do I say this why is that
relevant it's relevant
because this is not something
that is
new but some of us may think it's
new that there are a group of people and
a group of authors who say this never
happened how could this have
happened if no
other historian in the world mentioned
it right
imagine you have the entire world it's
not
just you have the entire world of people
who are sharing the same
Moon why is it that when we
research the works of
historians from east to
west we find that none of them
documented this
independently this is the
argument this is a very weak argument so
some
people will say and I've seen this
written and
mentioned in certain books and you
know people who are trying to give this
kind of
new modern translation explanation of
the
right and it's well you know we
went to the moon and we didn't see any
big split in the Middle where it would
have split so we can see the moon real
close and we don't see a seam where that
would have happened and we don't have
that and and you
know this this is something that
couldn't happen anyways because the Moon
is spinning and if it split open these
you know these kinds of thoughts these
kinds of
arguments okay so what do we do with the
verse there's Muslims saying this if
that's the case then what do we do with
the verse they say well what the verse
means the hour has drawn
near and the moon split doesn't mean
that it split in the past it's going to
split and this is on the day of judgment
on the day of
Resurrection when the horn is
blown and
the creation meets its end and the sky
is opened and the Earth is is tremoring
and the day of judgment is being
initiated the moon will then split
that's what the verse
means that's a problem why is that a
problem because linguistically it
doesn't work it's not something I will
explain in Arabic but no
serious
mu of the scholars
of have put in any argument for this the
scholars and the
companions agree that this is something
which occurred in the time of the
Prophet s. wasam let the moon split how
did it split well if the moon is
orbiting it's moving very fast and how
could this even H this is that's the
nature of a miracle it's something
that's inexplicable I I mean think about
it if you open that it's a it's
a thread on a on a cheap suit if
you pull that thread the thing will
start to completely
unravel if you think about it if we want
to rationalize every Miracle of the
Prophet s. wasam we're going to be
forced to interpret all of them to be
natural
occurrences I saw some
people rationalizing
that
when with with is when Pharaoh was
pursuing them they reached the Red Sea
and the sea was split they said no no
the sea didn't split the way you're
thinking no there was actually a
hurricane that was going through the
area at the exact same time and they
happened to come at the exact moment of
this hurricane and they were walking in
the eye of the hurricane it looked like
the seait
this
is
right and the reason that people do
these are Muslims that I'm speaking
about people who claim that they are
Muslim historians or claim that they are
explaining the Quran but they're
explaining the Quran according to modern
science and all of these things as if
the Quran is a book of geography or a
book on astronomy or as if the Quran is
here to just tell us about what happens
in
a you know in a in a woman's womb when
she conceives and what the Sun and Moon
are doing this is not the purpose of the
Quran and many many of these so-called
scientific miracles of the Quran that
are written and discussed and POS
posited they are not correct and they
are in direct conflict with the Arabic
language and more importantly they are
in direct conflict with the
understanding of the
companions this is an important point
it's kind of similar to the numerology
they say the miraculous numerology of
the Quran right so for instance
they'll say if you look into the
Quran you'll see
that you know this verse this number and
this number verse if we add them
together we get this number and if we
divide it by this over here we get this
number and the exact letters and B right
and they come out with they come out
with these
equations and these very far
out
conclusions but all of this is based on
what it's based on
presupposition because are the numbers
of verses in the
Quran is that something something we
took from the prophet Sall wasallam no
the companions didn't write
numbers they wrote only the words of
Allah that's it no page numbers no
chapter numbers no verse numbers this is
why the scholars of Islam they differ on
the number of verses in each chapter
they don't differ on the words in the
chapter they don't differ on what the
chapter says that's agreed upon but
counting this is an independent verse
and this is an independent verse or
counting them both as one verse this is
something that's different
upon automatically our numbers that
were you know predicating all of this on
these numbers are what they are the
work of they are not necessarily
something which is divine revelation
right and so they say that m
he was walking in a hurricane with B is
it was actually a you know a small
tropical storm just happened to be
cutting through the area the right time
and so M and you know they hopped into
the into the eye of the storm they you
know walked through the Red Sea and
this is their rational right and the
same thing with the people of the
elephant right Allah subh
says it says that Allah
sent flocks of birds flying over them
dropping on them you know
stones and that these Stones killed
these people who came with ABA to try
to destroy the Caba two years before the
prophet Sall wasallam was born some
historians mention the year the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was born then
they come they said well hang on a
second a bird in order to drop a stone
for it to reach a terminal velocity to
be able to puncture a human
skull has to be so and so miles in the
air
but birds don't really fly that high
right we're talking about 35 40,000 feet
45,000 feet birds don't really fly that
high no birds that we know naturally fly
especially in flocks that high so what
did they what did they explain the
verse to
me
[Silence]
right they said wellow you know this is
metaphorical it wasn't actually birds
and it wasn't actually Stones there was
an illness a disease a virus that spread
and then you know when they went back to
where they were from they all died
there this is conflicting with Arab you
know history is conflicting with Muslims
and non-muslims why because we want to
give every Miracle some kind of
explanation how did Allah do this like
okay I understand that Allah is saying
that he sent a flock of birds
upon them to defend the C how did he do
it what kind of bird was it and how many
Pebbles and what was the weight of each
Stone right this is
[Silence]
exactly
and so this issue with the moon
splitting they say well look no other
country or no other civilization that we
know
of at that time when the moon
split
documented this in their history
books this is only something in the
Quran this doesn't mean
anything first of all it's in the
Quran all of the Companions and and the
scholars of tap the major Scholars of
tap explain it to be as that there's
narrations of the Prophet sallam
discussing this he recited it for 20
years after after this incident and no
one not even his enemies said when when
did this Moon split we never heard of
this before they all it was a known it
was common knowledge Muslim and
non-muslim and finally this is an issue
which is a miracle it's a miraculous
someone all the way in Europe or so just
we have lunar eclipses we may see
it and a few hundred miles to another
Direction they don't see that right this
is an issue of Optics and but our issue
as Muslims is not that
we have to rationalize every one of
these things we don't it's it's like
saying okay the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam ascended to the heavens right
during well there's no Oxygen up there
how did he breathe when he was doing
that well there's no gravity how did his
body circulate blood properly
right first of all this is a nonsensical
question because in its Essence it is
something which
is Supernatural something that's beyond
the scope of what we know nature to do
that's number one it's a miracle that's
why it's called
that and number
two this is
this is the same line of
questioning that the disbelievers would
question with the prophet and
Messengers and the prophet Sall Al
wasallam woke up and said I was taken
subh that Allah says in the
Quran that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was taken in a very short
amount of time a portion of a night from
to and he told us the details of that
what did the people
of Islam say the companions they
said and what did the antagonists of the
Prophet say they
said
and
so this issue
[Silence]
of
this is the nature of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi was am's Miracles and
so one of these Miracles was that the
moon was split and it was
documented by the non-muslim Arabs at
the time and more importantly it was
documented by the companions more
importantly it was documented by the
Quran and sometimes you know it's almost
well you know we don't Muslim
historians say this happened but I'll
really believe it if a non-muslim Muslim
historian said it
[Silence]
happened
Allah
[Silence]
abbar